hi guys I made you guys some you today
in a while I'm here in Venice shooting
some stuff up plugged in his crew over
there a long few days of shooting he's
so exhausted and I've been sick
since Chicago which was like last I just
bought this shirt in the storm right
over here I needed one ran out of
clothes from the shoot so I thought hey
it's those fifty percent off sale i'll
show you how show you I'll show you
l
it's just found 27 who bought it that he
believes a nap oh look sale dots
ten-dollar five dollar I should have
bought should about this woman six time
there Seth
so one of the producer that's it pretty
good lunch Jeff did later so I got in
the car and I like pan this new shirt
that I just got it feels really
uncomfortable oh that's because I put it
on back horse this is the front at a
changing his back room because they
couldn't really see anything it was kind
of dark that's my excuse and i'm
sticking with it maybe I just haven't
learned to put my clothes on the right
way